Evet hepinize Merhaba hayırlı içli böyle
dokunaklı biraz ürkek içine kapalı bir
kız çocuğuydum Aslında annem önümüzden
geçen ambulansın ardından üç gün
ağladığımı söyler dur acaba içindeki
hastaneye Yetiştin mi kurtuldu mu diye
ilkokulda notlarım 1.25 Bir elin üzerine
yeşil tek hatırlamam Ama hani her yedi
yılda bir insanın saçının cildinin bile
kabuk değiştirdiği söylenir ya sanıyorum
Ben de tam 15 yaşında yatılı okul için 4
yılına işe gittiğimde kişiliğim
karakterim Tam da bu zamanda kabuk
değiştirdi sonrasında üniversiteye
gittim ama annemle senden ayrıldım
gerçeği hiçbir zaman değişmedi Bu arada
üniversiteye gittim 4 yıllık
bu Turkcell'de alelacele takdir teşekkür
de bitirdim sanki ilerisini görmüş gibi
televizyon bölümünü yanı sıra Bir de
psikoloji okudum mezun oldum döndüm bu
üç zaman okul sıraları çok sevdiğim
anlamına gelmesin çünkü sonrasındaki iş
hayatı benim her zaman gerçeğim ve
Aslında Hayat tarzım oldu yine küçükken
annem Bugün beni Taksim Meydanı'nda
götürmüş evde yolda Yürüyoruz birlikte
yoldan geçen bir de üzerine tükürmüş
annem da bir fikri koşa koşa eve
dönmüşüz beş gün boyunca benim çitile
çitile yıkamış bu Tabii ki benim 1999
yılında NTV de mavi olarak işe başladım
yazacak Taksim Meydanı son kez görüştüm
oldu Sonra 99 yılında en TV'de staj
dönemi başladı görünce kapıdan içeriye
girdim hangi bölüme girmediğim ne
yapmalıyım diye baktım işte Kültür Sanat
bölümü işte sanatlar sanat dersleri
sergiler var işte çokça konserler hiç
bana göre değil ekonomi bölümüne gittim
rakamları aramış bir zaman çok iyi olma
çok kötü F kahvaltılı basın toplantıları
Orası beni çok sarmadı spor bölümüne
geçtim İşte maçlar sporlar Yok burası
değil dedim en son haber merkezine
girdim istihbarat bölümünde Tam da
Kendimi buldum içimdeki o heyecan dolu
meraklı araştırmacı o soruşturmacı
adının tutkusunu sanıyorum En çok da bu
en TV'de altı yıl boyunca sahada
geçirdiğim yıllar çokça besledi yine o
dönem Bayrampaşa Cezaevi'nde F tipi
cezaevlerini protestolar var Bayrampaşa
zannedip O Ses sonra geliyoruz bir
telefon çaldı sanırsınız gizli Göreve
gidiyorum parmak ucunda evden çıktığımı
hatırlıyorum çatışmalar patlamalar en
son iki gün sonra tekrar eve döndüm
Kısacası kitaplarda okuduğumuz filmlerde
seyrettiğimiz o hayatlara demek Dokunmak
istedim Bu yüzden de hani benim mutfağın
Tamda ortasında olmanız lazım Oha
birlikte bu işi Mutfağı dır O yüzden o
yemeğin mutlaka biraz tuzu etmeniz lazım
Hatta iki Taka
o lazım Çünkü yaşamadan anlatılmıyor
anlatılsa da gerçekçi olmuyor o yüzden
bugün genel yayın yönetmeni olsamda
muhabir olarak kalmam hep bu yüzden
çatışmalar sorgular hepsi bir yana
Dursun sanıyorum duygusallık boyutunu En
çok da kol mesafesinde gördüm iki
yüzünüze de cesette test ettim yine o
dönem nişanlanıyorum Uzeyir garih Bizim
aile dostumuz nişana katıldı bir hafta
sonra ben de haber Merkezi'nde
oturuyorum polis telsizinden bir anda
son dönem polis terzi dillerde kodları
hala izin verebilirim Üzeyir garih diğer
Loto mezarlığında öldürdü diye olabilir
mi acaba dedim gerçek olabilir mi koşa
koşa gittim olay yerine baktım gerçekten
o kanlar içinde yatıyor borç çok üzüldüm
saatlerce ağladığımı hatırlıyorum bütün
bu olayı takip ettim katil yakalandı
duruşmalar başladı Fatih Adliyesi'nde
tek tek bütün oluşmadan hepsine katıldım
ve Adam dedi ki ben
bu ve Daha sonrasında aslında Sadece yer
almıştım aşağıdan yardım yardım diye
bağırdığında tekrar yukarıya çıktım da
öldürdüm dedi acaba dedim Mümkün
olabilir mi şubecilik işte gittim Pierre
Loti mezarlığında bir kum saati koydum
aşağıya bütün o merdivenlere indim
çıktım acaba bu kadar kısa sürede
öldürmüş olabilir mi diye belasız bunun
gibi çok kolay yaşadım kendi alanlarında
Lider olabilme potansiyeline sahip
kişilerin seçildi Amerikan Dışişleri
Bakanlığı'nın bir programı vardı bir
buçuk ay süren ben de buna davet
Evliydim işte Pentagon Beyaz Saray
gezilerinde içebildiği bir program o
dönem margarete açıyoruz Süleyman
Demirel hepsi gençliklerinde katılmış
oyunda programa daha denilen tek Türk
tüm nereden bilebilirdim ki yıllar sonra
meslek hayatında sırf programı katıldım
diye ajanlıkla suçlandım camı 19 yılı
aşkın meslek hayatında çok şey oldum
Aslında ergenekoncu oldum yandaş oldum
kendi ülkemin şu bayrağı
var yani bilirsiniz Amerikalı üzerlerine
Amerikan bayrağının tişört diğerleri
üzerine şort yerler ben kendi ülkemize
ay yıldızlı bayrağımız taktım diye bu
ülkede ırkçı faşist biri oldum galiba
kadın olunca Hedef olmak da bir o kadar
kolay oluyor ve Doğrudur Türkiye'de
kadın olmak kolay değil çünkü erkek
Egemen bir medyada mücadele ediyoruz
Çalışıyoruz hepimiz biz mesela bir Mayıs
hiç unutmam işçi Bayramı biz de o zaman
hep beraber bütün meslektaşlarıyla
beraber çekime gittik o meşhur Perpa
köprüsü üzerinde bir hatıra fotoğrafı
çekiyoruz resme baktım 22 yaşındaki bir
ben kız Bir de yine bir kadın
meslektaşım daha sadece iki kişiyiz yine
Geçen hafta sanırım önceki haftaydı
Çankaya köşkü'ne Başbakan televizyonları
ve gazeteleri Genel Yayın yönetmenlerine
çağırdı hep birlikte gittik üşenmedim
Saydım masada 43 kişi sadece ikisi kadın
biri de ben ne demek istediğimi Aslında
çok güzel ortaya koyan bir tablo bu
o Çünkü sanıyorum Bu erkek Egemen
medyada o kadar çok böyle çalıştık
çabaladık ki kadına ayrımcılığı pozitif
ayrımcılık kendi haber merkezinde
bilinçaltında uyguladım o yüzden bugün
İstanbul haber müdüründen Ankara haber
müdürü ne yurthaber editöründen dış
haberatör ne tamamını kadınlara teslim
ettim erkekleri yer gibi olmasın ama
kadınların gözüne ve kalbine çok
güveniyorum yaptığımız işte Zaten kalp
işi aşkla yapıyoruz biz yaptığımız işin
tutkuyla yapıyoruz Aksi halde zaten
yaptığımız işlemde Hayır gelmiyor
mekanik değiliz tabii ki Elbette Oh
büyüğü ekranın camın etrafında en fazla
da bir sırf alıyoruz rıp alamıyoruz ve
insan çok travmatik olaylara sahne
olunca sanıyorum kırılma noktalarını bir
o kadar fazla oluyor Benimkiler den biri
Mehmet Mehmet 7 yaşında annesiyle babası
boşanmak üzereler ve
da gayet davası görülüyor annesi Kur'an
Kursu hocası babası İmam ve babası bu
kararlardan farklı bir şehirde yaşamaya
karar veriyor bizde bu duruşmayı takip
ediyoruz ve doğal olarak Mehmet'in de
yaşı küçük olduğundan velayetini
annesine veriyor mahkeme sonrasında
annesiyle kalmaya başlıyor çocukta bir
altına kaçırıyor annesi döve döve ve
komalık ediyor memede buz gibi bir beton
üzerine koyuyor Sabaha kadar orada
bekletiyor korkusundan hastaneye bile
kaldırmıyor sonra anneanne geliyor
sabaha karşı ne yaptın sen bana diyor
işte böyle böyle diyor alıyorlar
hastaneye gidiyorlar Bir hafta boyunca
bu Ölümle yaşam arasında mücadele ediyor
hayatta kalmaya çalışıyor ama maalesef 7
yaşında veda ediyor bu hayatta Mehmet
sonrasında
Evet Ee h
bu Mehmet'in babası mı çokça etkileyen
bir olaydır beni Çünkü aklım hep şu
görüntü kaldı o velayet davası annesinin
kucağında Mehmet Mehmet ağlıyor Baba
Beni anneme bırakma beni çok dövüyor
diye anneside çimdikliyor Mehmet'e de
daha fazla bağırmasın diye o
haykırışları bir ay boyu gitmedi benim
rüyalarımdan sonrasında haber bitti
duruşma süreci oldu bende haber
sonrasında bir yorum yaptım İsyanım öz
annesi tarafından öldürülüp Üstelik
pişmanlık nedeniyle cezasının
indirilmeseydi indirilmesi neydi
Mehmet'in annesinin bir yorum yaptım
Neyse haberler bitti telefon çaldı
santralden arıyorlar Mehmet'in babası
arıyor dediler O anda kafam karıştı kim
Mehmet tabi bağlayın dedim Merhabalar
dedi Ben Mehmet'in babası ben dedi küçük
yaşında çok
Dur dur Aştım oğlumu olma kavuşmaya
çalıştım ama mahkeme izin vermedi dedi
Ben bu hayatta tutamadım Mehmet Ama siz
sözlerinizle bir nebze olsun benim içimi
falan anlattınız İyi ki varsınız dedi O
günden beri her bayramda her kandilde
Arar veremedim babası Mehmet'in babası
hiç tanımıyorum ama işte bir yerde bir
hayata Mehmet'in babasına ve Belki de bu
dünyadan göçüp giden o küçücük Mehmet'in
hayatını deyip dokundum o Mehmet gibi
sık o Mehmet gibi diğer memetler de çok
önemli oldu benim hayatımda benim ailem
de asker ya da polis yok ama benim bu
ülkenin askerine polisine olan sevgim
malumunuz Evet vatanseverim Atatürk'ün
ve en büyük şansım da bu topraklarda
doğup Büyümek olduğunu düşünüyorum Ama
buna karşılık bu ülkenin askeri polisin
her zaman çok yalnız olduğunu hissettim
yeter kadar önemsenmediğini hissettim
ve onların sesi olmaya karar verdim
Şimdi belki onları önemlidir dedim özel
bir günde onları Yanında olayım yılbaşı
gecesi onlarla birlikte geçelim dedim
Nereye gideyim nereye gideyim baktım en
uzak yeri neresi sınırda Dağlıca var
hani bir çoğunuz belki bilmez bile 2015
yılında 16 Şehit verdiğimiz yer Peki
haritada bile yerini zorlanırsınız ya da
çok çok haberlerde duymuş olabilirsiniz
iki helikopter bir uçak atladım gittim
yanlarına onlarla birlikte geçireyim
diye yılbaşı gecesi gidemedim güvenlik
gerekçeleriyle ve hava koşulları
nedeniyle iki hafta sonrasına verdi ve
tam 24 saat çekim izin var gittim işte
tank atışları top atışları hepsini
çektik 2753 rakımlı o beybuta tepesine
çıktık kuş uçmaz kervan geçmez bir yer
Hani burada görev yapabilmek için
gerçekten hayatta bir amacınız olması
lazım
en son Sevdası olması lazım bir bayrak
sevgisi olması lazım kocaman yüreğinizin
olması lazım çünkü hani Bunun
karşılığını Parayı ödeyemezsiniz burada
insanlar canını ortaya koyuyorlar gittim
işte bir mağara gibi bir yerde yatıp
kalkıyorlar zaten hava koşulları o kadar
kötü ki -20 derece Buz gibi soğuk insan
konuşmaya bile zorlanıyor iki metrekare
arada bir helikopter geliyor tepeden
kuma yatıyor askerler yiyebildiği kadar
yiyor böyle bir yerde yatıp kalkıyorlar
sizin için bizim için hepimiz için vatan
için sonrasında çekimler bitti Dağlıca
çıktık 1500 askerle birlikte bir gece
geçiriyorum şekiller bitti oturduk
sohbet ettik derken yatacağız hoş uyumak
ne mümkün odaya geldim
ne çıktı Kapı çaldı 20 yaşında Gencecik
ve Aslı ve Nazlı abla dedi bizimle
beraber biraz oturur musun Biz de seni
çok bekledik buraya geleceksin diye
oturmaz mıyım Tabii ki dedim gittim
yanlarına işte onları anlattığı kiminin
tersine şu kadar az kalmış kimi gün
sayıyor onlar anlatırken Ben de böyle
televizyona takıldı gözüm Çünkü müzik
kalın müzik alanın altında hani böyle
aşıkların birbirine notları mesajları
geçer ya işte her birinin bekleyeni var
Sevdalıları var o da yine sizin gibi
benim gibi bi çekimler bitti ve oradan
ayrıldım Bu arada Buraya giderken Annem
biraz Pimpirik de asla anneme nereye
gittiğimi söylemiyorum Ankara'ya
gidiyorum dedim olağanüstü Kurultay hal
kurultayda çekimler yapacağım günlerden
pazar artık 24 saati Devirdik One filoya
indik son şeyler birkaç saat sonra uçak
kalkacak oturduk bekliyoruz Bu esnada
Annem görüntülü telefondan beni arıyor
Efendim dedim atari küpelerine yeni
aldım güzel mi dedi kaş göz yapıyorum
şimdi atlama
Bu sesle görüntüyü olunca herkes bizi
dinliyor Ben dedim sana Bir yalan
söyledim Ben Ankara'da değilim Neredesin
dedi Dağlıca dayım dedim Orası neresi
dedi işte dedim böyle böyle Van Hakkari
Yüksekova indim bitti gibi Öldüreceğim
seni buraya gelince dedi Yeter artık
dedi Seninle uğraşamam mı arkadan ama
dedi inanmıyorum kesin orada değilse
anne Vallahi buradayım dedim Yok Yok
dedi hiç inanmıyorum dedim Şöyle bir
göstereyim yedi tane komutan oturmuş
annem bir anda ayağa kalktı önce
yedikleri saygılar efendim beri hepinize
Saygılar kızım size emanet etti gel
görüşeceğiz gel görüşeceğiz sonrasında
Yine yüksekova'ya gittim orada da yine
bombalar patlıyor sokağa çıkma yasağı
var Çatışmalar var dedim söyleyeyim de
hayattayım merak etmesin birazdan Çünkü
haberler başlayacak görüntülerde
anlayacak benim orada oldu mu önden
aradım nasıl bağırıyor bana hiç lafımı
dinlemiyorsun bıktım Yetti Artık vesaire
böyle bağırıyor bana baktım çok vermiyor
Ben de telefonu kapattım bir hafta
boyunca küstü konuşmalarını küs
ne dedi Başka çare olmayınca biz kaldık
sayalım derken aslında şehit haberleri
alışma Yalım derken en büyük tehlike
Aslında onlar da nusaybin'e gitmiştik ve
Nusaybin'de sokağa çıkma yasağı var
Çatışmalar sürüyor İşte biz çekimleri
yapacağız onlar operasyonu çıkacaklar
hep beraber masada oturduk bu yine
konuşuyoruz nasıl yapmalıyız bölgede ne
kadar gün kaldı ne kadar rahat
temizlendi terör örgütünden bunları
anlatıyorlar bir çayımız işte bir çekme
gittik onlara operasyona gitti Zaten
birkaç saat geçti tekrar geldi Oturduk
Aliye baktım Ali yok yanımda Ali nerede
dedim beni şehit düştü dediler evde
yüklü binada iki saat önce nasıl dedi
bu Ali şehit düştü Hani 60 saniyede
giriyor belki hayatlarımıza Şehit
haberleriyle giriyor ağlayan bir anne eş
5Y Team kalan cami avlusunda oynayan o
çocuklar sonrasında bitti diyoruz bizim
için ama onlar için hayat hep yarım
kalıyor Çünkü ateş düştüğü yeri yakıyor
onların hayatları Artık hep yarım
kalıyor Yine bir gün dağlıca'da
dönüyoruz askeri helikoptere bindi
karada bir çok nadiren kalkıyor zaten
helikopterler bir grup var asker onlar
da izine çıkacaklar artık Çarşı izlerine
çıkacaklar yüklemişler Balıkesir gibi
hep birlikte doğmuşuz helikopterin
içerisine bir giderken yanımda o skorsky
helikopterler in kobra kobra
helikopterinin pilotlarından ikisi
oturuyor dedi ki resmini çeker misiniz
dedi ama dedi sizde de bir selfie yapın
dedi bizimle Tabii ki dedim birlikte
böyle resim çektik aradan yirmi iki gün
geçti
ben Burak şehit haberi geldi
Evet Ee acıları hep biriktirdik ve Happy
Bedel ödüyor insan Ben de başta IŞİD PKK
olmak üzere onlarca davadan yargılandığı
hala yargılanıyorum ölüm tehditleri
meclise soruşturmalar bu hakaretler
tehditler ver mesela emniyet bir canlı
bomba listesi dağıtmıştı birkaç kişinin
canlı bomba olması nedeniyle bunda da
haberleşir misiniz bize haberleşirdi ki
gün sonra aşağıdan Aradılar beni
güvenlikten tebligat geldi lera dedim
herhalde ile dava açıldı gittim baktım o
haberini yaptığımız kızlardan biri sen
dedi Nasıl bana dedi canlı bomba dersin
ben de üniversite öğrencisiyim dedi yok
öyle bir şey dedi ben tabii adliyelere
gittim ifadeler veriyorum gittim geldim
aradan vakit geçti İki sene geçti
İstanbul'da Vatan Emniyet Müdürlüğünün
önünde bir çatışma 1 polis şehit
bu iki tane kız yatıyor yerde üstlerinde
bombalar bağlı ellerinde Kaleşnikof
tüfek ölmüş teröristler o kızlardan biri
Düşte bana iki yıl önce dava açan
otomatik Beraat ettim getirsin mi daha
fazla oldu götürürsün mü bir zaman
bilemedim ama fark yaratmak istedim ve
bu kurulu düzen de uyanları biraz dolsun
uyandırmak istedim Aslında ve ne
yaptıysam aşkla tutkuyla yaptım davalar
soruşturmalar haliyle her anne gibi
benim annem de yeter artık yoruldum
bırak şu dünyayı Sen mi kurtaracaksın
diyor Yok dünyayı benim kurtarmaya gücüm
yetmez Ama oturduğum koltukta Belki
biraz olsun Bir şeyleri değiştirmeye
gücüm yeter diye düşündüm ve ben herkes
kendi kapısının önünü süpürürse farklı
bir Türkiye olacağına inandığım her
zaman kızıma bırakacak koca koca binalar
Imm arazilerin yok belki ama bir şeylere
3 ilmek adına çabalamış bir annesi
olacak yol bir yerde bitiyor bitecek
Elbette hepimiz için önemli olan kaç
kişinin hayatına dokunduğumuz ve kaç
kişi için fark yarata bilmiş olacağımız
olduğunu düşünüyorum Hepinize
teşekkürler